to our top story six people are dead
after a plane that came from Las Vegas
crashed in California this morning this
happened outside the French Valley
Airport in Murrieta 8 news now reporter
Madison Kimbrough is live near Atlantic
Aviation here in town on Koval and
Tropicana where that plane took off with
more tonight Madison
executive term
that unfortunately this morning's
takeoff ended in tragedy with a deadly
Landing
according to the Federal Aviation
Administration just after 4 15 Saturday
morning the Cessna 550 crashed in
Murrieta California near French Valley
Airport in Riverside County killing six
people on board while the cause of the
crash is still under investigation the
national Transportation safety board
shared what they know about the plane
and its potential Landing it again
appeared to be privately owned the
weather was at the minimums for landing
at that airport so the visibility and
ceilings allowed for a landing but it
was right on the minimums according to
the Riverside County Sheriff's
Department the plane went down in a
field when the sheriff's department
arrived on the scene they found the
aircraft engulfed in flames 8 news now
stopped by Atlantic Aviation where the
plane took off and spoke to a pilot who
says this type of aircraft that was
involved is typically a reliable one 550
has been around
probably 35 years I mean it's just got
his excellent safety record
it's a popular airplane typically these
airplanes can be flown by owner Pilots
okay so uh you know that that's that
requires a level of proficiency that
sometimes uh is and doesn't take place
yeah it was pretty much lined up with
the runway as for what's next both the
Federal Aviation Administration and the
NTSB will continue to document evidence
on the scene Gathering witness
statements looking at security video
and our plan is to just examine as much
as we can on scene before it gets
damaged because it's invariably does
when it gets removed and then we'll
remove it to a secure facility the next
couple of days
as of now the victim's identities have
not been released but we do know that
one of the victims was the pilot
reporting here near Koval of Tropicana
Madison can grow eight news now now this
is the second plane crash near French
Valley Airport just this week one person
died and three others were hospitalized
after a plane went down after taking off
their that crash still under
investigation